every year i give leslie the same
present i give everyone a crisp 20 bill
and every year she gets me
something thoughtful and personal
it makes me furious
this year she outdid herself
she had it installed over the weekend
it's so
so beautiful
leslie has anniversaries for everything
zoo day first time we went to the zoo
together double date day was the first
time we went on a double date daniel day
lewis day talk like a pirate day talk
like a pittsburgh pirate day which why
and how this calendar was last year's
calendar day present celebrating the
first time she ever bought me a calendar
you have to buy a present for every one
of these she always tells me not to but
then she buys me something that's
awesome and thoughtful and then i feel
terrible but that's the thing this is
the perfect present i just keep getting
outbid by someone named tall tyrion
lannister what kind of name is tyreen
anyway
you're kidding right i know we agreed on
no gifts what but i did get you a gift a
bunch of them actually i was gonna
surprise you with them yesterday but
they never reached you
oh my effin god ah you planned all of
this for me an enchanted carriage this
is amazing oh and your scrapbook
instincts are really good i mean this is
a little rough but you have a lot of
talent here ah i can't believe i
actually defeated leslie knope at a gift
exchange yes
uh yeah
about that
happy anniversary
[Music]
it's the iron throne oh
it's the iron throne yes it is i had a
guy at the model store make a replica
he's a bigger game of thrones fan than
you are
okay i know i'm making that dumb
surprise face but i can't help it this
is the greatest gift i've ever received
leslie
when you play the game of thrones you
win or you die
yes
no
yes
no come here come hither peasant come
here who are you
our starship is in trouble okay leslie
listen if you're not if you don't know
what you're talking about
leslie wishes she could be here herself
to give you these presents but she's
suspended oh and also she said that
they're not from her they're from santa
claus can i go first
mouse rat
certified gold over 100 copies sold in
pawnee
i need to get a picture of me holding
this so i can frame it
personalized leopard printed robe pink
feather cuffs and on the back in
rhinestones
you can get it i know you're sad you
couldn't get tickets to the watch the
throne tour so i got you a watch and a
tiny throne instead and check it out she
even took out the dumb clock part and
put this in
baller time
these are the black eyed peas
and i finally killed them
it's a christmas miracle
we need to get leslie something that
erases the enormous emotional debt that
has built up over years of this
gift-giving imbalance everyone start
thinking of ideas oh geez
socks
she gets me i have presents um
chris we got you an acai tree because
the acai berry is a superfood and a
super gift donna we got you some coffee
because you said and i quote i like my
coffee like i like my men dark rich and
full-bodied yes indeed and we got you
some very rare hawaiian fertility tea
guaranteed to help you have a baby
that's so nice where'd you find that
well the busboy at our restaurant um
told us about a guy who we met in a
parking lot and then he had a backpack
full of this stuff and i'm just
realizing now that it's not tea and i'm
gonna throw it away ron this is the
hawaiian god of anger it reminded us of
you when you're at work a handsome
gentleman we did not forget jerry right
we got jerry some earbuds and a bag of
peanuts
and skymall catalog same thing you got
me from your trip to washington tom we
got you an autographed portrait of your
personal hero
no way scott carr from hawaii favor
april as requested we threw that box you
gave us into that volcano
thank you
andy as you requested got you a three
pack of white t-shirts from target thank
you all mine are dirty
thank you hawaii hi hi hi hi sorry i'm
late i was off getting holiday gifts for
my team william here is a nope 2012 tree
ornament hey elizabeth i got you a knope
2012
menorah maybe
no no okay then i got you a tree
ornament
what's going on here merry christmas
leslie
we made you this replica of the parks
department out of gingerbread oh my god
i love it oh i love it and i love you
guys and ann specifically and all of you
you did all of this together
yes
except for me
turns out i cannot make a gingerbread
house which would bother me if i were an
eight-year-old girl
in any case these people stepped up and
helped me out and that gave me another
idea
this is the city council chambers
and that's you next may
i don't understand
happy waffle day oh my god
you guys this is the best breakfast day
waffle day joint present i have ever
received wow thank you so much you're
welcome but anne and i wanted to tell
you
that this is a last breakfast day and
waffle day we'll be celebrating wait
what
oh my god you're both dying no no we
just can't keep up with all the
anniversaries it's too much especially
because you're so good at them i don't
know better at them than you are that's
ridiculous i'm so much better point
taken but we have a compromise every
year there will be one day and day where
you can celebrate all of anne's holidays
and ben day where we can celebrate all
of ours what about anne month and ben
month
how about a week
fine
we went in with a day
figuring she'd counter with a month we
were fine with the week
but there will be a third week it will
be called friend week it will be
commemorating this week the week that my
two best friends became each other's
best friends i have a friend week
present for you right now here you go
how did you already have these
thank you thanks hey that box has my
name on it hey this one has my name on
it this one has plates name on it
you have just found your buddy boxes
each box contains a memento of our
friendship i was going to give them to
you later but
there is no time like the present
fun pun alert
a bronzed hamburger it's from our turkey
versus beef cook-off remember you were a
worthy adversary i would have preferred
a regular hamburger for eating but this
is very nice 2008 indiana state audit
spreadsheets and that year was insane
that was the year you went from being an
auditor to a legend whoa
a picture of me officiating leslie and
ben's wedding and look you can just
about see my head
thank you so much
slag juice
i thought these were destroyed by the
fda i did have to go to a very seedy
location to find it but now i know where
to go to place a better horse fighting i
got this city of pawnee mug also this
cool jacket no i think that's chris's
jacket okay good then we know he likes
it catch up larry okay i found some old
receipts from lunches we had together is
that anything this is my contribution it
says ron hey guys what's going on oh
we're just uh giving you a bunch of cool
gifts
get your hopes up chris let's see
some
assorted items
and
some pieces of paper
boom nailed it all right now we can
start enjoying this party
all my life i have avoided europe and
its multitudes of terribleness but it
turns out much to my surprise there is
actually one place in europe that is
worth seeing
these tiny islands off the coast of
scotland where god's chosen elixirs are
distilled barreled and prepared for
consumption
this
is worth the trip
dear ron you have now reached the
cliffsides overlooking the islands as
you sit here and gaze upon the waters
please read out loud the poem by the
great scotsman robert burns
love leslie
a worm i love yon lilac fair with purple
blossoms to the spring
and i a bird to shelter there
when wearied on my little wing
how i would mourn when it was torn
by autumn wild and winter rude
but i would sing on wanton wing
when youthful may it's bloom renewed
[Music]
i don't know what she thought i'd get
out of that
[Music]
why aren't you
what's that
oh you too
i i couldn't i couldn't quite hear you
please don't make me say it please
my going-away present to you will be
that i do not make you audibly say
that you love me
thank you
okay leslie's coming back get off you
went did i miss a nice moment no yes you
did oh
good
you